les bureaux de vote sont en effet au
vert à 8 heures ici à perpignan les
premiers électeurs sont arrivés très tôt
pour glisser leur bulletin dans l'urne
parmi eux louis aliot candidat du
rassemblement national qui affronte
aujourd'hui pour le compte du second
tour des élections municipales son grand
rival jean marc pujol maire sortant l
est républicain second tour est bien
dont l'enjeu sera la participation
puisque 39 % seulement des électeurs ont
participé au premier tour du scrutin
un second tour aujourd'hui un peu
particulier puisque on le rappelle il
intervient plus de trois mois après le
premier tour c'était le 15 mars s'en
était suivie une crise sanitaire liée
aux qu'ovide sans précédent en empêchant
toute tenue de scrutins aujourd'hui la
situation à sanitaire s'est améliorée le
port du masque reste toutefois
obligatoire à l'intérieur de tous les
bureaux de vote du gel hydro alcoolique
est aussi mise à disposition et la
distanciation social est demandée pour
tous les participants
le premier tour a fait scandale on le
rappelle puisqu'il a été maintenu malgré
tout les inquiétudes du moment sur la
propagation du colis de 19 d'ailleurs on
le sait de nombreuses personnes avait
été à l'époque contaminés lors de ce
premier tour donc c'était le 15 mars
dernier